die bilder die wir ihnen jetzt zeigen
die sind wirklich wir eingang ein
wildschwein rennt herum ein nackter mann
hinterher weil dieses wildschwein sein
laptop geklaut hat daraufhin sollte die
freche aber laut netzwerk berlin super
liebe so abgeschossen werden aber das
letzte wort ist in diesem fall noch
nicht gesprochen
da sind sie schon wieder die berliner
wildschweine auf futtersuche hier zu
sehen am teufelssee im grunewald
ebenfalls der schauplatz dieser kuriosen
szene von letzter woche ein nackter mann
verfolgt eine wildschwein mama und ihre
kinder die sich eine tasche geschnappt
haben und es sind noch mehr allesamt auf
futtersuche es ist normal dass
wildschweine so nach einkommen an der
beschriebenen stelle am teufelssee ist
es schon fast tradition erleben schon
seit jahrzehnten immer wieder neue
wildschweine die sich an menschen
vertraut machen und natürlich da auch
gerne hingehen und ehrlich gesagt es ist
ja wie ein supermarkt liegt so viel
futter dass es nur nachvollziehbar ist
für die bachen für die wildschweine
füchse marder und natürlich auch
waschbären da hinzugehen zu fressen für
das forstamt grunewald ist genau das ein
problem
es seien zu viele wildschweine und sie
scheuen den menschen nicht mehr
als konsequenz sollen die tiere
entnommen werden im klartext die
wildschweine sollen geschlossen werden
doch nicht sofort denn es ist der moment
da nicht möglich die wildschweine zu
jagen
viele badegäste sind schließlich vor ort
und auch die frischlinge kann man nicht
um ihre wildschwein mama zurücklassen
die jagd ist also noch nicht eröffnet
und auch eine friedliche lösung für das
schweinische problem ist noch nicht in
sicht so lange müssen die berliner
badegäste weiterhin mit den wilden
besuchern rechnen
und manchmal gibt es ja auch was zu
lachen definitiv gerettet die wildsau
und wir scheinen jetzt zu meinem
kollegen peter wilke und peter ich
übergebe dir einfach direkt das wort ja
wir stehen hier am teufelssee in berlin
grunewald vorher waren wir am vorstand
ganz der nähe von ihr
da hat die aktion fair play man noch ein
paar teilnehmer hinter mir sieht zum
protest gegen den abschuss des
wildschweins hier am teufelssee
aufgerufen jetzt sind wir hier an den
ort des geschehens wo er die
wildschweine in den letzten tagen für
aufsehen gesorgt haben gegangen um uns
das alles noch mal von ihrem mann schon
wir haben auch gerade die wildschweine
schon wieder gesehen wie sie hinter uns
im wald vorbei gelaufen sind und bei mir
ist sonja wende die organisatorin der
aktion fair play des protest ist hier
sonja kannst du uns vielleicht einmal
erklären warum genau protestiert
ja wir sind heute hier um gegen den
abschuss der wildsau elsa und ihrer
frischlinge zu demonstrieren dieses
wildschwein ist ja in den letzten wochen
relativ bekannt geworden dadurch das ist
ja im badesee einem gast die sachen
geklaut hat und diese bilder sind um die
welt gegangen und haben die leute sehr
erweitert und ein lächeln ins gesicht
gezaubert und nun ist er da diese
berühmtheit zum verhängnis geworden und
sie ist zum soll zum abschuss
freigegeben werden und dagegen möchten
wir demonstrieren heute warum seid ihr
denn dagegen könnt ihr dann gar nicht
nachvollziehen dass es für menschen die
hier am teufelssee bahnen dass sie sich
durchaus gefährdet durch das schwein
sehen und auch die berliner forsten
sagen dass es dazu angriffen kommen kann
durch das wildschwein
also ich habe schon verständnis dafür
dass vielleicht einige badegäste erstmal
komisch gucken wenn sie dieses
wildschwein hier so nah dran sehen wir
haben ja gerade schon beobachtet wie das
ja so abläuft dieses tier hat ist
wirklich sehr neugierig und die besucher
aber allerdings waren anscheinend schon
daran gewöhnen wir haben auch in der
vergangenheit schon mit besuchern
gesprochen und die haben ja dieses
wildschwein erst auf den namen getauft
das tier ist also hier bekannt unter den
besuchern hat quasi so eine berühmtheit
erlangt als das wildschwein vom badesee
und ich hat sich von den besuchern mit
denen ich gesprochen hatte sich
überhaupt niemand bedroht gefühlt im
gegenteil das ist eher so ein highlight
und zum magnet um hierherzukommen weil
wo hat man schon so dicht die natur vor
augen mit dem wunderschönen teufelssee
aber auch den wildtieren direkt vor der
nase
von daher wenn leute natürlich angst
haben kann ich das verstehen wir wollen
ja auch niemanden irgendwie das
vergnügen am sommer verderben aber
dieses tier wohnten mal hier im wald und
deswegen hat es auch eine berechtigung
hier zu sein und ich finde da müssten
sich mensch und tier arrangieren und
bisher hat das sehr gut funktioniert
und da sind wir nicht da für diese
friedliche koexistenz durch den schuss
des jägers zu wenden ja wir haben also
gehört die haupt fragestellung ist hier
wie kann man die existenz von elsa dem
wildschwein und ihren beiden
frischlingen und den badegästen hier
gemeinsam vereinbaren
die berliner forsten sagen es muss der
abschluss kommen die tierschützer von
aktion fair play sagen das geht auf gar
keinen fall ist funktioniert auch so